hi
we should have reacted or recorded guys
this is a situation where i'm not able
to get my hands in front of me right so
maybe he's specifically trying to hold
my hands behind me so i can't get around
my hand and i can't get him in front of
me so i can't get to my weapons i'm in a
bad position here what i do is i use one
of my hands to isolate his wrist then i
turn my thumb up towards so the
thin part of my forearm goes towards the
weak part of his grip i lock my arm to
my lower back and turn my entire body
out so i'm not just pulling with my
shoulder i'm turning from my hips here
the kodo guy she's going to be waiting
for me i bring this hand up and roll
immediately into the coat of guys bring
him down
from here my free hand's going to go to
the elbow and i'm going to rotate his
body over i want him face down so that
way it's harder for him to use weapons
on me i drop my inside knee the other
hand the free hand comes up and grabs
here specifically on the wrist so i'm
grabbing him uh much like a yakute dory
from this side i drop the knee and come
in i'm hooking the arm here driving down
up and over one more time at speed
a